I wasn't raised in a foodie home I
didn't have a no not Gianna make sausage
or Bobby to make matzo balls or eating
only organic gluten-free rice crackers
or grass-fed free-range bison no much
like many picky eaters of busy families
of my generation I grew up eating things
like gain super fries and Hamburger
Helper
unbelievably or not so ompletely anxious
mothers take note I grew into a food
loving healthy professional eater food
blogger home chef food scholar and
registered dietician now all food
snobbery aside one of the things my
upbringing is Todd meat is about the
power of food in bringing people
together and eliciting an irreplaceable
sense of pleasure
these early lessons have helped me to
balance my sometimes competing
identities despite being a dietitian my
experiences and memories around the
dinner table have helped me to
appreciate food as much more than mere
nutrients numbers calories and portions
food is
love culture traditions identities
sensuality so in my practice my research
and my everyday life I've discovered
that having a pleasurable relationship
with food is one of the most essential
components to good health and for me to
be able to accept my fate as a foodie
dietitian I set out on the goal to
dispel the myth that eating well has to
be boring you're bland instead to
demonstrate how it can be flavorful
satisfying and maybe even a little bit
sexy I mean if you think about it and I
hope you will eating and sex are not
dissimilar activities they're both
embodied manual sensual intimate
pleasurable shared health promoting and
pretty much essential to life at this
point but I really want to encourage
people to hold on to the tradition of
enjoying every taste and touch and smell
of food as they would other stimulating
counters I'm not here to preach to you
simply here to inspire you to go out and
experience food with a new tour eásá t
we think so
follow me eat with me learn with me join
me on a series of a gastronomic
adventures welcome to a DS kitchen where
nothing says lovin like something from
the oven I hope you brought your
appetite
you